do you miss me they miss me
they miss me i know
they look at their bad ratings and
they're saying we miss this guy
i said it was gonna happen i was waiting
for them to endorse me actually
i know that was a big step but they're
going down the tubes their numbers are
very bad
and cnn's remaining three viewers are
saying
yeah he's got a point
[Applause]
you know it's another glorious monday in
this horribly racist country
i mean really what a racist country i'd
ask cat how racist
it is but it's not like she's paying any
attention not after what happened this
weekend
how you open a locker so i bet you're
wondering greg how racist
is this country well it's so racist that
even its buildings
are bigoted did you know that the
rotunda which houses
the declaration of independence the u.s
constitution and the bill of rights
is guilty of structural racism yep the
national
archives task force on racism claims the
structure itself portrays our founding
fathers
and other evil white people as too
positive
shocking that the national archives task
force on racism
found evidence of racism
i mean i thought they'd say hey looks
good
and then spend the rest of the day
eating funyuns in bed
which as you know are also racist side
note i always thought
rotunda was spanish for fat lady
according to the new york post the
report claims the structural racism
deeply impacts how employees and
customers interact as well
as with the historical records they're
finding structural racism in the actual
structures
the rotunda's bigotry quote lauds
wealthy white men in the nation's
founding while marginalizing
black indigenous and other people of
color and women
but i wonder how can they say this
without even knowing which founding
fathers
identify as gender non-conforming
remember these chaps were wearing wigs
way more than rupaul's drag race
hey we're a healthy pack of pervs
also using their criteria couldn't you
say this about a lot of other buildings
i mean how did the white house skate by
on this
and how long before we changed that name
but you see
the rotunda holds all the major
documents all written by dead white men
and if all you see is skin color and
gender then it's got to piss you off you
get
to the rotunda and you find out there
are no female apaches
who wrote the declaration of
independence that
sucks but what do you expect going to
the rotunda and expecting people of
color to be credited for the bill of
rights
is like me going to a hockey game
searching for an ashkenazi z jew
or zoo it's like me going to the wnba
in search of a wife
they're twice my height it's not going
to work out
or it's like you going to cnn looking
for an honest journalist
the task force suggests tips however to
reimagine the rotunda
including staging dance or performance
art in the space
that invites dialogue about the ways
that the united states has
mythologized the founding era so first
let's address the idea that adding
performance art to anything makes it
better
that's like adding milk duds to a
pepperoni pizza
and that suggestion is pretty insulting
to people of color to assume that they
can only contribute
the crappiest of art which is
performance art
when white liberals have no solutions
which is always they always turn to
performance art
which is really just improvisational
back spasms
some mindless emo pretending they
slipped a disc
that's i just i'm a performance artist
now about this mythologizing of the
founding this is coming from people who
spend every waking hour reimagining
stuff
they say the founding is not just
exclusionary it's a myth a fantasy
something that never existed
like bigfoot or brian stelter's gym
membership
because anything positive about america
has to be reimagined is horrible
like you're suddenly awakening from a
dream and it's really a nightmare
which happens every time i mix nyquil
with skunk weed
a trick cavuto taught me now you could
rewrite history and come up with a new
declaration of independence add some new
signatures a black guy an indian a new
zealand weightlifter
because now every event has to look like
a community college brochure
even if it's not true i wonder what the
angry white male has to say
the founding fathers i love them
i do i can't tell you how much i
appreciate everything they did to make
this great country of ours that's why i
keep a picture of them behind my desk
these guys not these guys
although these guys are pretty cool too
aren't they i mean come on
dogs playing poker it makes me laugh
i don't think though those dogs were
there by choice though
so i wonder what the angry black male
has to say about this
[Music]
racist buildings
are building races
like when you ring the doorbell and
gives you a racial epitaph
or every time black mailman comes over
the mailbox lean back
you know it's kind of cool that we live
in a country that you can
make like this up and say whatever you
want and speak if you want to be given
the platform
to call anybody in their mom or racist
or even a building i mean that's
pretty much says that uh you live in a
free country that
let you say anything no matter how
stupid
systematic opportunity
and speaking of at least we have a new
american hero
gwen berry america's hammer thrower
which was my dad's nickname when he
drank
[Laughter]
she turned away from the american flag
as she stood on the metal podium at the
olympic trials during the national
anthem on saturday
she says she was pissed the song was
played as she received the bronze
claiming the timing of the song was
intentional too bad there isn't a medal
for paranoia
but imagine being caught off guard by
the star-spangled banner
at an american olympic event
that's like being stunned when you hear
the safety dance
at a men without hats concert
so there you go you got a person who
like the national art archives task
force on racism takes things that are
inherently positive for a country
and recast them as simply deeply
offensive to gwen the song is an attack
on her
the same way the rotunda is an attack on
people of color i'd say this is nuts but
that would be an attack on cisgender men
i mean we're a week from july 4th our
nation's birthday why do we even bother
celebrating it anyway
of course besides mixing alcoholic
drinks with explosives
but if a building can be racist and a
song could be racist can't a date be
racist too
imagine some old guy heading to the
rotunda on the fourth and decides to
sing the national anthem god forbid he
might be a veteran of some big war
how soon before we turn our backs on him
[Applause]
welcome
she's uncovered more plots than a
gravedigger director and producer of the
documentary the plot against the
president amanda milia
[Applause]
his first job was at burger king now he
calls out the democrats
whoppers former oklahoma state
representative t.w shannon
she wouldn't hurt a fly she's too busy
torturing her husband
fox news contributor cat tips
and jaws saw him and asked for a bigger
boat my massive sidekick and joseph
said on fox station iris
so tyrus it would be kind of fun to
actually see a racist building
like that would actually act like what
how you expressed it yeah that would
be real fun depending on who the racist
building was mad at
every time you duck and keep opening the
counter you know the bathroom leave
it what yeah you know it would just be
like non-stop
just turn the tv on and it's always on a
cross burning who's saving them
yeah but they're not because they're
inanimate objects so
yes it's not really really real but it
sounds good though i mean because that's
the
the whole point of you can say anything
and especially now it's never been a
better time in this
country to be uninformed and just catch
a headline on facebook and then
get in front of the camera and just just
go to town because even if you're wrong
no one's going to tell you because it
comes from your truth
yes exactly good luck finding the roots
on that one but
what bothered me so much about and
here's the deal uh i i get in this
there's a
you can have two thoughts just like i
said you have two thoughts in your head
especially when you're dealing with
citizen athletes and citizenship right
uh i think you can
take causes we've seen historically
everyone remembers this
everyone remembers what muhammad
sacrificed muhammad ali because he
didn't believe in the war
there was consequences but history looks
back on it now going they're the heroes
right nowadays we can say anything
without a face to it or
like i'm against systemic racism okay
well what is that
it's systemic racism and if you can't
see it you're racist
right so you can't argue with that yeah
and by turning your back and this was my
issue with her by
turning her back on the flag when you
turn your back on something
that means there's no hope there's done
like every every
mob move we've ever seen i got to turn
my back on you now jimmy you know it's
over like it's over it you can't fix
that
so that was what my issue was i didn't
have issues with guys taking these
during the flag because they're standing
for what they believe in the following
whatever you can still love the military
and protest was going on in our
government but that to me what she was
doing
was simply saying there's there's
nothing can be done it's a horrible
place
but she doesn't have what's your cause
yeah that's the problem there's no face
to it
martin luther king won martin luther
king one you know president barack obama
won
tim scott won i'm sitting in this chair
i won we won
we're seeing it everywhere you go what
this country is about
and to be in such a safe place to where
you can pull stunts like this
she wasn't dragged off the yeah and
beaten with an inch of her life she
wasn't having a firearm
she hasn't even lost her spot yeah
that's
so you can say whatever you want in this
country because that's where we're at
right now where
words matter but they don't really
matter because you're in a safe place no
one's coming for her
yeah so congratulations on taking away
from the two
um in front of you that's the thing uh
tw i felt bad for the other two and no
and i just found out because i didn't
watch any of this i only got the news
off facebook
because i was drunk all weekend let's be
honest gw
there were two other winners in the the
the gold like or the
the one she broke a world record yeah
that was the thing that got me she came
in third place that's the first thing i
mean
if you're gonna make a protest at least
you know have the gall to win
but you know i think every american
should stand for the united states
uh national anthem i mean it is a
rallying call for who we are as a people
this country has done more
to make dreams come true than any
country in the world and i don't know
who she turned her back on whether it's
america the national anthem
but i'd like to ask who's she turning
her face to what country is she going to
look toward where she's going to be
treated better
than she is here in the united states of
america that's the problem that i have
with this woman but again
you know she's probably angling for her
next deal i mean this is what
you know marxists for hire do right they
look for an
opportunity to continue to spread this
propaganda about how racist america is
when has been mentioned america is a
place of sustaina systemic opportunity
she'll probably go on
to join the ranks of people like
michelle obama oprah winfrey
and meghan markle who all claim to be
oppressed in this country
but happen to be millionaires a
billionaire so that's probably the
future she's looking at but
unfortunately
she did it at a place in a time where
really she brought you know really shame
on this country we should all stand
for the united states national anthem uh
that's just period and i don't care who
you are
yeah you know amanda i just i thought it
was neat to think that the
song was about you like sometimes that
happens to me when i'll be in the gym
and uh
and i'll just start you know having
thoughts like i probably think this song
is about you
exactly i'm so vain that moment
yes i mean it's totally insane because i
mean i don't watch a lot of olympics i
know
nothing about like great athletes and
and all of that
the one thing i do know about the
olympics is that when there's the people
standing on the blocks
at any moment they're going to play the
national anthem like that's the point
i'm like oh this is when the flags go
and they play the national anthem like
how does she not know that
yeah how does she how was she surprised
i mean i guess it was like all about the
timing or whatever she said but um
the idea that she thinks that they did
it on purpose to mess with her head
is um a level of paranoia that i haven't
even gotten to yet
i mean as a as a olympic athlete myself
i was deeply offended by all of this uh
i got a passion for hammer throwings do
you you have passion for hammer throne
no
you've had a bunch of hammers thrown at
you i'm sure i'm not sure what that
means
i should be upset probably at a hardware
store you'd wander in a hardware store
drunk off your ass cat oh that's yes i
have to tell you though i think it's
really great that you've gotten into
horseback riding
i saw the writing crop in your office
that must be what it's for
right yes it is it is it is
okay i like i alright i do so hammer
throwing
it is it is a great sport it is a
tremendous art to do so
but i think the real issue was and kat
i'm surprised you didn't jump on this
was
she was upset because of the timing yeah
as soon as she heard she's been running
her mind you know she's been telling
everyone she's going to do
yes and then they played the song so she
had she wasn't ready
right if she was waiting for the
olympics to do it because you can't
stand for this one
and then go in the olympics and do it
there somebody ruined it and you
are a stickler for timing cat quickly
about the the buildings i
do want to say they also recommended
trigger warnings which i don't know why
we're still
doing that because years ago multiple
harvard studies showed best case
scenario
they do no good but they could also
potentially
create more harm particularly for trauma
survivors i'm surprised that this task
force didn't know that
yeah it's like it's multiple pieces of
research from harvard showing this and
they're like oh yeah trigger warnings
yeah hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else